hey guys what's up I'm Daniel and this
is DLM model lifestyle where we talk
about grooming fitness style and
modeling life now in this video we're
gonna talk about one of your questions
can I be a model if I'm short the last
people who asked this is why K creations
and Varun there's a lot of other people
that asked it and I asked certain questions
like can I be a model if I'm 5 5 or 5 7
or 5 3 well yes and no I'm just gonna
talk as I prepare for a casting I'm
currently in South Korea where I'm here
for a contract for a few months and we
have to go to a casting in ten minutes
but uh yes an no you can be a model
if you're short and you also cannot it
depends on what type of model there's a
couple of types of modeling there are
high-fashion models and those models
need to be tall that's just something
that is it is how it is right all right
but apart from high fashion modeling
there are also a lot of other types of
modeling that a lot of people don't even
know about there is commercial modeling
there is social media modeling there is
plus-size modeling there's Fitness
modeling now these kind of jobs differ
and you don't need to be tall for all of
them fitness modeling you don't need to
be tall if you have a good body give it
a shot then you have social media
modeling that's become very popular in
the last few years why probably because
of Instagram there's some people who
gain a lot of followers and then
companies reach out to them and say hey
could you please help us out and promote
this product for us and we'll pay you a
certain amount of money if you do decide
to go that direction please don't just
say yes to any company and just sell any
product that you haven't tested yet all
right you want to bring a really good
service to people you want people to
trust you so don't be one of those
people who just they just want to make
money you know and it's all about money
and they say hey look at this product give
it a try and it will work wonders and
ugh... it's just like lies coming out of
their mouths don't do that don't be that
kind of person if you want to do
plus-size modeling you don't need to be
that tall either now commercial modeling
is more closer to high fashion modeling
the only difference is that the models
look a little bit different the
commercial models are  those kind
of people that you can relate to the
next-door girl or guy the one who is
very friendly and somebody you can
really relate to right so those are the
people who are more smiling more
friendly and they can also do fashion
shows they can do TV commercials they
can do photoshoots they can do a lot of
different jobs I am a commercial model
and I do photo shoots and the commercial
models are actually well from my point
of view commercial models are the best
if you look at making money but if you
want to be a local model then sometimes
your height doesn't matter that much but
if you want to travel as an
international model then yes there is
height requirements your height
requirement is very important you need
to be 185 minimum for guys there is a
little bit of leeway I have seen a few
guys that is 183 184 but that's very
rare or girls you need to be 174
that's the minimum 175 even but there's
also leeway and I have also seen some
girls that that's shorter some girls
that's around one six nine one seven but
they have really good bodies and facial
features so they work a lot in TV
commercials and photo shoots for
underwear and swimwear so just ask an
agency if they like you and they will be
very honest and say hey yes we can let
you travel internationally there are two
reasons why you have to be a certain
height if you want to be an
international model number one is
because of the sample clothes the
clothes are a certain size and they only
fit models who are a certain height all
right that's the one reason the second
reason is most the international
agencies they only accept models that's
a kind of one in all model meaning they
can do all the jobs the reason for that
is the modeling changed in the last few
years it's now it is something that's
very competitive there's a lot more
agencies and there's a lot more models
out there so for an agency to take a
chance on a model they'd rather book a
model that works good in most of the
jobs meaning they do fashion shows TV
commercials photoshoots and other kind
of jobs so it is easier to be a model in
your home country than it is to travel
as an international model
so just to recap if you want to be a
model there are options number one
social media Instagram Facebook YouTube
you don't need to be very tall to be a
social media kind of model number two
fitness models fitness models there's no
height requirement so you can be very
short but you have a amazing body and
then you can be a fitness model all
right number three plus-size model as
well just be plus-sized and then the
last one the commercial models and a
high-fashion models yes those models
need to be a little bit taller with the
commercial model so you can be a little
bit shorter if you have a good face and
a good body but with the high-fashion
model there's no leeway there for
fashion shows and to be a high fashion
model
you need to be taller if you want more
modeling tips check out my new e-book
called modeling a guide for beginners
and professionals the book is more
focused on fashion and commercial models
and it deals with topics such as making
money posing castings modeling agencies
and a lot more I have added the link in
the video description down below so you
can go and check it out so that's it
guys I gotta go to the cast thing yes I
gotta run if you liked the video give me
a thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you
in the next video
cheers guys